in Islam if you have God Allah just
forgiving you just because you asked you
still have the sin that's undal with you
still have the sin that's just being
swept under the rug and therefore Allah
is showing Mercy by forgiving you just
because you ask but he's sacrificing his
justice so he's unjust when he forgives
without dealing with the sin hello how
you doing um we were talking the other
day and I I guess you got banned on
there too I don't know you're always
getting banned I guess
I'm always getting banned okay well I
guess just to start I would I'll add to
what you were just talking about which I
don't really know the background of that
conversation but for me that particular
verse isn't problematic I wouldn't I
wouldn't say I understand it the same
way that he does I would say that I
would just read it how it is like like I
don't see that verse problem problematic
how it is by itself for us I think we
UND like you're saying that God is Not
powerful because he can't do something
with because because he needs someone
else he depends on someone else to be
able to do something okay we're saying
that he doesn't do that it's not that he
can't it's that he doesn't because it is
against his own nature well so so that
if he did it he wouldn't be God like
you're saying he's not all powerful
therefore it's not God but we're saying
if he did do that he wouldn't be God so
Allah having a son so you're saying that
it goes against his nature so he can't
do that is that correct he can't have a
son because that goes against nature yes
okay so when Allah says in the Quran if
he wanted to have a son he could have
just taken one from among any amongst
his creation so Allah saying that he
could go his nature and have a son if he
wanted to well it depends on how you
understand son right so the two the two
verses right you're talking about one
where he says he could have taken a son
from anyone amongst the Nations that's
how we understand the bibl term anyways
like when people are prescribed as a it
would be in theal sense in the other
sense where like actual kind of a
begotten son how you guys describe Jesus
he would need you know another person in
order for that to happen and that would
make him less than God no none of that
makes any sense okay I want to so for
example the same thing would be like if
you said if I asked you can God lie how
does that okay because for us we say
that God can't lie it's not us saying
that God you know that that makes God
less powerful because he can't do
something just that God doesn't lie and
that goes against his nature I know what
you mean how can you show so again can
you show me how God having a son goes
against his nature demonstrate that if
he had a son in the physical sense like
with the wife that would go against his
nature so in that verse because that
would entail a lot of different things
that God doesn't do how no I mean how do
you know what goes against his nature
the way that he described himself got
very good so where does he describe
himself as it being impossible for him
to have a child without a partner
because from what the Quran says it
shows that he can do that with a partner
uh there's uh nothing like him those
sort of things so that doesn't that does
that doesn't say anything about him
being unable to beget a son well
begetting something is like a it's a
human thing says who okay what what does
it mean to beg get to bring forth bring
forth what bring forth whatever you can
bring forth anything can be get a
business I can be get children I could
be get you know my vision okay so when
you say that Jesus is the begotten Son
of God that just means that go don't go
to Christian theology we're asking about
Allah's Allah your theology when it
comes to Allah where do you get it from
that it is against his nature because
sir eass does not tell you this so where
do you get it from and it's against
Allah's nature to be that he's unlike
his creation okay for example does does
Allah have mercy yeah you have mercy yes
now Allah's Mercy is infinitely more
than yours right yes but you guys are
the same in that you have the attribute
of Mercy correct yes so he is something
he is like his Creation in some sense so
similarity for the F the example we have
thei that we are created in God's image
right but our image is different In His
Image right so like you said God has
Mercy we have mercy right but our Mercy
is not the same as his mercy so it's you
could say I wouldn't use the word
similar but like the trait is there like
we have mercy he has Mercy but his Mercy
is nothing like our Mercy okay no
worries so you guys you are similar to
Allah that you have the trait of Mercy
right sure okay good so either you have
a problem with the verse when says that
there's nothing like there's nothing
like him in creation either you have a
problem with that or you're just
misunderstanding that and that it mean
that he's absolutely unlike you in every
sense because obviously there are some
senses in which you are like Allah you
have his image have some of his likeness
obviously mistrial scale but you have
some of similarities to him right so
nothing like when we understand it means
like we're not the same as so like I
said our we both have Mercy but our
Mercy is not like his Mercy meaning it's
not the same it's not the same type of
Mercy his Merc I cor with that so the
same way Allah can be and humans can be
but his beginning is not like your
beginning okay and so when you describe
be getting right it's not just bringing
forth is it something different like
what is bringing forth bring forth so
now now when you when you do it in human
like humans we if we're beginning like
physically you know that's through
sexual means now Allah may be able to be
with a partner differently than how we
begin with a partner but just like we
can begin is beginning is just different
okay so with that definition right if
we're just saying bring forth okay which
I don't think that all Christians would
Define it the same way as you're saying
right now because well let's just say
okay we take that definition all right
for us then you could technically say
right if you're using that definition
and I don't want any and the Muslims to
turn on you but like you could
technically right that God brought forth
Jesus using Mary right which we would
necessar but like I said I don't think
anybody else would use the term beget in
that way like I don't think anybody
saying that God just brought forth
otherwise I mean there's no problem with
that
necessarily good that is the that is the
belief so there is no problem there is
no there is no problem logically when
you deduce it
with saying that Allah is the be is the
begotten I'm sorry that Jesus is the
begotten son of Allah no real problem
that taking it with that definition and
like and like I said whenever a Muslim
reads those verses anyways they would
they would understand it in a
metaphorical kind of in that sense
anyways right all right got you so now
let's go back to this now so now we've
just demonstrated that it's not against
Allah's nature to be or even have a son
he says he can do it in the if he wanted
to he says he could do it with a partner
if he wanted to and so now we're back to
the problem the problem that we have is
is that he can't do it without a partner
according to his own words how can how
can he have a son when he doesn't have a
partner which means he needs a partner
to have a son okay say that again okay
so the verse says how can he how can he
talking about his ability right
is talk about ability capability how can
he have a have a son when he doesn't
have a partner which means that in order
for him to have a son he needs a partner
to do it okay I would say that the
definition the word when it says begot
there that's why I said the definition
that you're using is is kind of shaky
because whenever God's talking about
begotten there that's not what it's
meant talking
the human version of
begot the word begotten does not appear
in that verseo well I mean that's how
we're translating it right I don't know
what is the you know word the word
begotten is not there it's nowhere there
that idea is not there it just says how
can he have a son when he doesn't have a
wife or I'm sorry have a companion
that's that's all it says he's the
originator of the heavens and the Earth
the creator of all things okay so the
son for us like even still right he
can't have a son because it's talking
about the physical sense in the sun
right like the human version of the sun
like how you would be doesn't it talks
about Allah's version of the sun it says
it's talking about Allah remember we we
we have similarities to with Allah
according to y' theology right we have
like certain Baseline similarities and
likeness however his in in every
category is you know different than ours
but Baseline is the same so having a son
can be different than how we have a son
even if it's very similar it's similar
but different but he can't do it without
a partner according to the verse so that
I believe is in response to the
Christians that would say that God has a
actual son which there are I've met
Christians myself that say things like
that that Jesus is the actual Son of God
like well actually it's a response to
the polytheists the Christians are
nowhere mentioned in the context but you
know I you know sure it can be in a in a
response to to Christians as well but
the problem is that Christians nor did
the polytheists say that God had a wife
or a partner to have children so that
that refu that response wouldn't make
sense but this is what does make sense
what makes sense is because this is his
reput his reputation right you're right
it's his response to these people that's
saying that he has a son and his
reputation is guys I don't even have a
partner so how can I have a son you know
we we now that's to for our
understanding from our understanding we
we we need to have children you need a
you need a partner you need a companion
to have children so Allah is using that
logic to refute them I can't have
children because I don't have a partner
how can I have a son when I don't have a
partner so stop saying that I think it's
cleared up with the other verse that you
mentioned about how if God wanted
someone who could choose from the
Nations right yeah but he would have to
do it with the partner it says he said
he can choose from amongst his creation
but he would have to have a partner I
think that again I just think that's
just talking about the in the physical
sense if he wanted to have a
metaphorical son then he could just
choose from the Nations and it and it
wouldn't be a problem but that's not
what that's not what the text says
matter of fact there is no real well
there actually is one there is one place
where Allah being a father in a
metaphorical sense is talked about and
then and also rejected like when the it
says the Jews and the Christians say
that they're the sons of Allah
his beloved ones and he says then why
does Allah punish you for your sins no
you are but men and Allah punishes who
he wills and he forgives who he will y y
y so he rejects their claim to be
children of God obviously they were
claiming to be children of God
metaphorically in the sense that he
loves them right they're his beloved he
is their belove they're his beloved ones
but other than that we don't see that
type of that type of talk okay well go
back just real quick on the on the sun
thing I think that I think that's kind
of like a semantical I think the biggest
problem is when you say that like when
you bring into like God because you
don't just believe Jesus is the begotten
son you believe he is God himself right
so you're saying that him being the
begotten son is him that's Christian
theology we can get there in a second
the problem here is bro is that Allah is
saying that if he had a partner he could
have a son and their accusations could
be could be legit but because he doesn't
have a partner he doesn't have a son he
needs a partner to have a son that's
what the that's just what the verse says
okay what what verse chapter 6 verse 101
how can he have a son when he doesn't
have a companion okay okay I'm going to
I'll look into it I guess some more and
and see what I can find out about it but
uh I'll just I'll let somebody else talk
or whatever but did you did you have a
question on the sunship of Jesus um
um
uh I don't know okay I guess I'll ask
this what makes you think that his
sunship is literal or how would you
describe it yeah so this is how it's
described when Jesus is the begotten son
he's truly the Son of God he's really
the son of God because he comes forth
from the father's Essence and so he's
eternal eternally infinitely begotten
from the father's Essence he's eternally
brought forth from the father so that's
what makes him the begotten son because
he actually is brought forth from the
father's Essence so he wasn't brought
forth at any particular point in time
yeah there is no point in time where
this where this bringing forth this
begotten this begins there's no point no
point where it starts it just it always
is okay so can I ask okay so there's a
Psalm right and I've heard different
Christians give me different answers for
this but the psalm is about whenever I
read it I think it's David I think you
might know what I'm talking about but it
says on this day I have begotten you
some people okay some people will say
that's David talking some people will
say it's Jesus talking which one do you
think it is about Jesus talking or
something it's both so David in the
immediate context is he's the speaker
but he's not speaking of himself he's
speaking prophetically about the Messiah
does this a lot actually he talks in in
first person as if he's talking about
himself and things happening to him when
none of these things happen to him he's
not in any of these type of situations
and it's not his words but he's speaking
prophetically of the Messiah so these
are the messiah's words that David is
reciting which the Bible says it's by
the spirit of Christ that prophets
prophesy the spirit of so when it says
on this day or today I have begotten you
you said that there was no point where
he became begotten but now you're saying
that it's Jesus in Prophecy saying today
you have been begotten or today I have
been begotten like Jesus is saying I've
been begotten today right well yeah so
this is this is a different context of
begotten so in this context and if you
read starting at the first verse all the
way through seven you'll see that it's
talking about one it's talking about how
the nations are rising up against Yahweh
and his Messiah so it's not about David
it's about the Messiah and how Nations R
up against him right and then it says
and God says that he scoffs at the
Nations he laughs at them as he places
his King which is the Messiah on his
holy heel on Zion his holy heel his holy
mountain and says that he will inherit
all the nations and it'll all be his so
this is where his King when God sets him
as King on the mountain that's his
inauguration David you're talking about
it's talking about no it's talking about
the Messiah okay it's the whole time is
talking about the Nations didn't rise up
against David okay this is talking about
the Messiah this is end times where the
Messiah the nations are rising up
against God and in the Messiah which
they try to rebel and stuff like that
and the Messiah God places the Messiah
as King on his holy mountain and the
Messiah destroys all the nations and
inherits all the nations so begotten
here is in the metaphorical sense it's
not the same sense as
the this yeah so this right here
begotten is being used as his
appointment as king of of the nations in
the world and his inauguration as God's
King on his Holy Hill it's his
inauguration and so actually Hebrews
chapter one talks about this too like
because Hebrews Hebrews 1 quotes this It
quotes Psalm 2 and applies it to Jesus
and says that this is now being applied
to Jesus after he has dealt with our sin
redeemed us of our sins and now has has
been exalted to the right hand of the
father and so boom now that inauguration
took place him as king and inheritor of
everything of all things okay okay okay
how would you how would you so why do
you take that in the Met metaphorical
Sint but when any other time Jesus is
called the begotten son of son why
wouldn't you just say that he is the
appointed he is Appo in that sense yeah
because so Hebrews 1 gives us more cont
so the context of PS to gives us shows
us that it's an inauguration of the
Messiah of his kingship and his
rulership on God's holy mountain it's
the context that that tells us context
shows that this is a metaphorical
begotten this in referring to his
kingship and his inauguration as king
and ruler and then Hebrews 1 puts it in
that same context Hebrews one talking
about the Sun how is it's so this let me
just show you how Hebrews one starts
Hebrews one starts off by saying that
Jesus is the son through whom God
created the worlds God created
everything so he's already he's always
been the son right let me uh let me just
pull this up real quick and show you how
Hebrews one breaks this down who is
Hebrews B again is this Paul uh some say
that it's Paul some say that that's it's
Luke at the dictation of Paul um they're
they're not really exactly sure exactly
they just know that it is Apostolic
because person claims to be an apostle
claims to be a witness of Jesus and
these things so we know it's Apostolic
stuff like that so it has Apostolic
Authority does that not does that not
worry you at all that you don't know
exactly who wrote it not exactly because
the the church the churches have
accepted it and have known it Church
fathers quote from it so it's not only
solid on its on scripture in line with
the other books of the Bible matches
them perfectly but also the person
itself the writer claims to be an
apostle and claims to be you know have
the authority of the apostleship and the
church agrees okay I'm G I'm going to
let you get to the verse but the only
reason I'm asking you about that is
because for me right and I don't know if
I told you but I was a Christian right
and the biggest thing that I had was
probably you know not knowing the office
but also like Paul not knowing why he
should be acknowledged from the first
like OB like people would wouldn't call
him a prophet for most people I know
wouldn't call him a prophet and so the
apostles the apostles Peter James and
John the disciple ananas they all seem
uh approved and attested that he
received Revelation from Jesus and gave
him what they call the U the hand of
brother Brotherhood I'm sorry they
counted him as a brother and one who
received Revelation and said yes you're
you're supposed to go to the non-jews to
the Gentiles as Jesus sent you and we're
supposed to
go to the Jews as Galatians Chapter 2
okay we'll come we can come back to that
but I can you I'll let you do the
Hebrews so this this how Hebrew says so
it starts off saying long ago at many
times and in many ways God spoke to our
fathers by the prophets but in these
last days he has spoken to us by his son
whom he appointed the heir of all things
through whom also he created the world
now the word word actually is ages time
so he created not just the worlds but
time itself he created it through Jesus
his son so here we notice that he
created the worlds he created the
universe through his son
correct so that would mean that Jesus
was his son always he's always been the
son even before he took on flesh and was
born as a human boy he was always the
Son of God okay from the beginning now
it continues it says he is the radiance
of the glory of God and the exact
imprint of his nature that's what it
says about the sun he's the radiance of
God's very own glory and the exact
imprint of his
nature all at all times yes okay right
so obviously God God's nature is is
infinite and eternal right mhm
so if Jesus is the exact imprint of of
God's nature then he also will have to
be infinite and eternal right or else
he's not the exact imprint of his nature
but he is he's the exact imprint of
God's nature of his substance which
means that Jesus the son also is eternal
and infinite in his nature because he
shares the same nature as God the Father
even flesh like that flesh is another
nature that he adds to himself but yeah
even in flesh as the Divine person he
has the divine nature and then he also
takes on a human nature that doesn't
conflict with his divine nature it
doesn't mix with it it doesn't he
doesn't become less Divine you know or
his human nature doesn't become Divine
like no he has the divine nature and he
also has the human nature and these
Natures don't mix in him they are two
distinct Natures that are just United in
the person of Christ in the person of
the son how exactly that works don't ask
me man I ain't God I don't know
but it's just what he what he what he
says about himself okay okay I have a
lot a lot of questions about that but I
mean but okay so all right so let's
continue so right so he says he is the
radiance of the glory of God and the
exact imprint of his nature and he
upholds the universe by his power by the
word of his power excuse me so the
universe is being up upheld by the word
of the sun the sun is the who's keeping
the universe
together um and now now watch this so
after making purification for sins so
after this after making purification for
sins after he came died for our sins
redeemed us it says he sat down at the
right hand of the Majesty on high the
father having become as much Superior to
angels as the name he has inherited is
more EX ENT than theirs for to which of
the Angels did God ever say you are my
son today I have begotten so notice how
we we've already established that he is
the son who sustains the universe who is
the exact imprint of his nature right
he's already identified as the son but
then later it said after his
purification of sins and after he
handled business on Earth he ex he was
exalted next to the father and then it
says for which of the Angels did God
ever say you are my son today I have
begotten you or again I will be to him a
father and he shall be to me a son that
is his inauguration that's when he is
exalted he is inaugurated as ruler and
King and inheritor of all things so
that's that's that's how I get the the
understanding or the context of the
begot of that type of begot okay okay
I'm gonna look into it like I said I got
one more question okay and then I'll let
somebody else go about the the bearing
of sins or whatever right like Jesus
bore the sins of of Van kind obviously
is the belief right so how do you
reconcile that with the Old Testament
saying things like you know no man can
bear the sins of another or the father
can't bear the sins of the son and
things like that yeah Ezekiel 18 it's
real simple so we're going to read
Ezekiel 18 it's 18- 20 so this what it
says it says yet you say God respond to
Israel why should not the why should not
the son suffer for the iniquity of the
father when the son has done what is
just and right and has been careful to
observe all my statutes he shall surely
live he shall surely live the soul who
sins shall die the son shall not suffer
for the iniquity of the father nor the
father suffer for the iniquity of the
son the righteousness of the righteous
shall be upon himself and the wickedness
of the wicked shall be upon himself s
but if a wicked man turns away from all
his sins that he has committed and
here's the key part and keeps all my
statute and does what is just and right
he shall surely live and he shall not
die now here's my question oh let me
finish you none of the transgressions
that he has committed shall be
remembered against him for the
righteousness that he has done he show
it now according when it came to
Redemption what was God's statutes when
it came to atonement for sins what was
his law on that
um there was the main one that people
bring up the sacrifice so like sacrifice
of a lamb or something that's right he
had to give a sacrifice it was a blood
sacrifice that was required for the
atonement of sin so notice a lot of
people try to use this verse to go
against the atoning sacrifice of the
Messiah when it doesn't doesn't go
against us and matter of fact it
reinforces that the wicked person has to
turn from his sins and keep all of God's
statutes that includes the statutes of
the statutes of atonement which means he
has to give a sacrifice so
substitutionary sacrifice is still
implemented in the law and statutes of
God so the Messiah is that all the all
of that stuff was pointing to the
ultimate sacrifice and substitutionary
atonement which is the Messiah so the
Messiah is still in on this is that
atoning sacrifice for mankind now the
father like you know the father can't
die for the son's sins and son will be
punished for the father's sins this is
still in line because they have to give
their own sacrifices a father has to
give his own sacrifice for his sin to be
forgiven a son has to have his own
sacrifice for his sins to be forgiven
they can't swap out it has to be own
okay so likewise with the
substitutionary sacrifice of the Messiah
the father a father who has sinned has
to trust in the Messiah as his atoning
sacrifice to be forgiven and redeemed
and the son has to trust have his own
faith in the Messiah to have his sins
forgiven and atoned for he his faith
cannot cover the sins of his father and
the father's faith in the in the
sacrifice can't cover the sins of the
son they have their own faith that makes
them right with God because of the
sacrifice that the Messiah has given
okay so what makes you what makes a
Christian believe that sacrifice is the
only atonement because like you said you
said the statutes of atonement
so we go when we go to the Torah good
question when we go to the Torah
Leviticus 17:1 it says this Leviticus
17:1 it says for the life of the flesh
is in the blood and I have given it for
you on the altar to make atonement for
your souls for it is the blood that
makes atonement by the life so according
to the law it's the blood that makes
atonement for the by the life I can't
hear you pause I can hear you now though
oh okay is that so is that that's the
only way that's the only that's the only
way for atonement of your sins now
obviously there there will come times
where God was lenient when it came to
you know people who couldn't afford oxes
and bus and Lambs they couldn't afford
that they may have only pigeons or like
flower or incense he would allow such
things or allow a priest to make up for
that um but all of that was pointing to
the blood sacrifice because in my in my
conversation with Jews right from what
I've been told is that the Christians
have kind of boiled it down to sacri
that sacrif sacrifice is the only way
whereas in the Jewish belief and
similarly in the Islamic belief that
it's one way and it may even be one of
the better ways but it's not the only
way so like like you said in times where
you don't have a sacrifice it's not like
you can't be forgiven anymore there's
other ways to gain forgiveness right
well it's not that they're gaining
forgiveness bro they're being
temporarily covered it's a temporary
covering you know which is why they had
to keep giving these sacrific IES and
keep they had to keep giving something
they had to keep giving either the blood
sacrifice if they couldn't afford it
then then the flower and the incense and
stuff like that you know they had to
give the sacrifice what Jews would try
to tell you actually is that all we and
and Muslims will tell you we don't have
to give a sacrifice for God to forgive
us he can just forgive us if we just ask
that's what Muslims teach and that's
what some of the rabbi Jews teach today
however
especially for a Jew that's false
obviously because we're reading the law
right now you have to give a sacrifice
two even in Islam you know that's that's
different theology so in Islam you can
probably say that but then again in
Islam if you have God Allah just
forgiving you just because you asked you
still have the sin that's undal with you
still have the sin that's just being
swept under the rub and therefore Allah
is showing Mercy by forgiving you just
because you asked but he's sacrificing
his justice so he's unjust when he
forgives without dealing with the sin so
okay I I would disagree just because
when we say that like the ones that
would be kind of swept under the rug
would be sins against God but obviously
like if I sinned against you like if I
stole money from you right I would have
to return that money before I could be
forgiven for that sin isn't that a sin
against God too it is but the part in
order for my sin against you to be
forgiven you would also we would have to
have a clean slate you get what I'm
saying whereas if I if I if I take if I
do take the money from you and I spend
it and you're like you know what you
don't have to pay me back then you're
within your right to do that you get
what I'm saying so do you see so do you
see how so not only can a sin against
God be swept under the rug so he's
unjust in dealing with sin but also my
forgive God my forgiveness is contingent
on whether on a human my my my salvation
and forgiveness of God is determined by
whether or not the a human forgives me
for what I've done well you don't
necessarily have to forgive me right you
just
thees you don't forgive me then God
won't forgive me you don't necessarily
have to forgive me though so like if if
I gave you the money back right and then
you say well I'm still not going to
forgive you I've done everything in my
power to make things right now that's on
your on your scales whether or not you
decide to forgive me or not because
obviously we're taught to forgive and
things of that nature all right know and
so that that's that's even submitting
the fact that your like the the
Forgiveness of God for you is dependent
on whether or not I forgive you for what
you did to me if I choose not to forgive
you then Allah won forgive you I don't
he would though he could still forgive
us even if you decide not to would wait
wait so you're saying so even if I don't
forgive you Allah Allah would still
forgive you yes so then that whole thing
about sinning against man and getting
right with me is relevant yeah that's
what I'm saying though if if I so okay
if I steal the money from you right and
then I give it back and then you still
say I don't forgive you right I've done
everything I could to try to get that
back now it's a deficiency in you for
not forgiving me now it's not that that
I've done that there's something wrong
now if you everything's been said
correct then there's no reason you
shouldn't forgive me now that's on you
and that's a sin for you correct if you
if you steal from me you've committed a
sin whether I forgive you or not God
still has to deal with you right so God
has to deal with you now if he chooses
to forgive you without without
punishment sin is swept under the rug so
God is mer Allah is merciful but unjust
sin is is not dealt with but he's
merciful he's forgiving okay so how is
that different from okay so now there's
a sacrifice so what what's different
about that now so I the money now I
steal the money from you and then I make
a sacrifice how is that any better so
what you need what what what happens is
is that you need a situation where God
is loving and merciful but also just at
the same time where he doesn't lack in
either quality so in his L obviously you
don't have that he lacks in his Justice
for his Mercy Mercy actually there's a
Hadith that says this he says let his
let his Mercy overweigh or outdo his
wrath that's what he says or out do his
justice so you have in Christ when
Christ is the sacrifice he Bears all of
our sins so when Christ is is dealt with
I'm I'm sorry when Christ takes the
punishment sin because it's on him sin
is being dealt with sin is being
accounted for sin is being punished
while at the same time God's mercy and
forgiveness is coming to us because of
what Jesus has done so not only is God
just in that he handles sin and deals
with sin and punishes sin but he also is
merciful and forgiving in that he
forgives us who committed the crimes he
forgives us and is merciful for us
merciful to us he's both at the same
time with No Lack no inconsistency and
so
so Jesus being the sacrifice is it his
flesh that is being sacrificed or is it
God himself being sacrificed it's God
himself in the flesh so obviously he
can't die in his divine nature he can
only experience death in his human
nature but it is the person of the son
who is God who takes on the sin and
takes on the sacrifice that's why the
that's why the sacrifice is infinite and
eternal because the person who gave his
life is infinite and eternal okay all
right I'll leave it there I'll let
somebody else talk obviously I'm not
keep coming back man you're asking Good
Question come back and ask and ask more
questions uh at a later date but like I
said honestly I'm not I'm not learned
I'm just I'm a I'm a newbie to this
whole thing I honestly to religion in
general so I'm just learning just just
really quick so you are a Muslim right
yeah so you said one of your one of the
problems you had with Christianity was
like the authorships of the the Bible of
the New Testament
mhm okay and I know you're about to go
so I want I want to leave this with you
I want you to have that same scrutiny
and applying to the Quran ask yourself
who wrote the Quran not who compiled it
not who collected it who are the people
that actually put pen to paper and wrote
down the Quran not the copies the
original who wrote down the Quran who
wrote down Surah Bak who wrote down
surlas who wrote down Surah IM who are
these people have the same questioning
with the Quran just think about that
look into that come back one day and
tell me what you find okay inshah thank
you for talking take care brother all
right bye